Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Ciao a tutti, buongiorno!
Io mi presento innanzitutto con un video
per anticipare vari discorsi.
Grazie!
Bloccato immediatamente
dal numero 99 De Angelis!
Io ho sempre giocato
a football americano in serie A.
Norberto ha iniziato a Parma e
poi è stato un pilastro a Milano,
poi da lì si è distinto
ancora di più portano lustro
alla nostra Nazionale campione d'Europa.
Ha partecipato e vinto dei trofei
di grandissimo prestigio.
Io presi la decisione, andai in Africa
per fare del volontariato.
Dopo un mese e mezzo ho avuto
un incidente in Africa
e mi sono svegliato in Italia.
Quando ti ritrovi in un letto d'ospedale
dopo un coma,
pensi che tante cose devono cambiare.
Mi dispiace Norberto,
tu non camminerai più.
Mi sono ributtato in gioco e ho riprovato
con uno sport aerobico che è l'handbike.
Mi sono illuminato quando ho visto
il film Forrest Gump,
quando rompe le stampelle e i tutori
e comincia a correre e non si ferma più.
Nulla era impossibile per Norberto.
Poi una grandissima sfida:
l'attraversata in solitaria dell'America.
Norberto, te la sentiresti
di tornare in Africa
e di ripercorrere in handbike
i luoghi del tuo incidente?
Ok, va bene!
Norberto, non è facile
trovare le parole per cominciare.
Il video parla abbastanza chiaro
qui davanti abbiamo un guerriero
uno di quelli che non si arrendono.
Lo dimostrano le tue avventure.
Già 3000 e 800 chilometri,
un coast-to-coast in America,
una cosa importante
e forse anche queste braccia
testimoniano il tuo coraggio e la
tua passione.
Nell'87 campione europeo di
football americano
con la nazionale ad Helsinki.
Corretto?
- Sì.
Poi in Tanzania è successo un incidente
e da lì la tua vita è cambiata.
Sì, sono andato in Tanzania per fare
questa esperienza di volontariato
e mi son ritrovato
per cercare anche delle risposte.
Mi sono trovato in una postura diversa,
però... è la vita.
E lì che cosa ha deciso di fare?
Di non arrenderti senz'altro, no?
E' una cosa che viene naturale
anche l'operaio
che non arriva a fine mese
decide di non arrendersi
e in maniera onesta tira avanti.
Io ho sempre fatto sport,
ho vissuto sempre di sport
e ho sfruttato lo sport per portare
messaggi educativi in primis a me
per venire fuori dal mio guscio
e poi anche per le persone.
Bene, infatti in Tanzania se non sbaglio
i Masai hanno visto in te
un vero e proprio guerriero.
Mi piace raccontare questo aneddoto
perché ti hanno regalato una lancia
che è un simbolo di potere.
Sì sono arrivato in un villaggio Masai
e mi hanno accolto alla festa Masai
con costumi locale mi hanno detto
- tu ci ha insegnato come si combatte
nella vita - e mi hanno regalato
una lancia e uno scudo
e han detto
- con questa lancia potrai
continuare a farlo
mi hanno fatto diventare
un loro guerriero masai.
E ti sei calato bene nella parte!
Ma l'anno scorso sei ritornato
e hai percorso 800 km su una handbike
adattata per le strade africane,
quelle strade dove tu avevi già percorso.
Quelle stesse strade del mio incidente
che dal villaggio di Matewmbe,
dove io vivevo ventidue anni fa,
fino alla capitale Dar Es Salaam
che era il percorso che ho fatto
all'epoca dove ho avuto l'incidente.
E una mattina ho anche attraversato
la curva stessa dove ho fatto l'incidente.
La persona che era con me mi ha detto
- ti ricorda niente qua?
Io ho detto
- no, cosa c'è?
Dice - quella curva lì è dove hai avuto
l'incidente.
Per me essendo stato in coma
era tutto lo zero assoluto.
Emozioni zero.
Hai esorcizzato comunque il momento.
A proposito di esorcismi, che cosa
volevi portare?
Perché sappiamo che l'Africa è un
paese complicato,
quindi anche la disabilità.
L'Africa è un paese complicato e bisogna
entrare un po' nelle loro cultura
per capire certi equilibri.
Io sono andato giù, non ho portato soldi,
non ho portato attrezzature,
io ho portato un messaggio di conoscenza
nel senso che i disabili
in Africa sono i poveri dei poveri,
perché chi nasce disabile
è un reietto della società e vengono
abbandonati,
Anzitutto non ci sono disabili fisici
perché non ci sono le medicine
non c'è la chirurgia
son quasi tutti disabili sensoriali
o traumatici o malattie.
Ho conosciuto dei ragazzini che mangiavo
come gli animali come le galline
che beccavano per terra il mangiare
perché vivevano nel pollaio
con le capre e quindi erano pieni
di vermi e di decubiti e non parlavano.
Una madre che partorisce
un bambino disabile vuol dire
che in un'altra vita aveva peccato
e viene punita e abbandonata
dalla famiglia dalla società.
Molti disabili
soprattutto nell'interno africano,
perché nelle città stanno cominciando
un po' a cambiare le cose,
vengono, cercati, catturati e uccisi
perché vanno dallo stregone che gli dice
per avere buona sorte seppellite
un pezzo di disabile
un braccio... e questo a maggior
ragione negli albini
perché gli albini essendo bianchi
pur non avere disabilità
però hanno un colore diverso
non avendo la melanina
loro vengono cercati e uccisi
perché l'albino rappresenta il bianco
il bianco rappresenta potere e ricchezza
quindi uccidere un bambino albino
vuol dire diventare ricco
nella loro cultura.
Io gli ho portato
un messaggio di conoscenza.
Ad esempio un pilota
di macchine da corsa
abituato ad andare via ai 300 all'ora
non ha paura dei 300 all'ora.
Una persona che è abituata ad andar via
in bicicletta agli 80 all'ora
se va via ai 300 si terrorizza.
Però se una cosa la conosci
diventa normalità.
Allora dicevo ai disabili
- fatevi vedere, fatevi conoscere.
Io stesso ho portato questa testimonianza
in prima persona
e io par loro ero un qualcosa
di molto strano
perché per loro non esistono
i disabili bianche perché
i bianchi hanno i soldi e possono
comprare le medicine per curarsi
che non è sempre vero, però.
Questo messaggio di conoscenze
perché man mano che le persone conoscono
questi problemi,
le persone diventano normali.
Il messaggio di conoscenza
porta normalità.
Ho conosciuto anche una famiglia
fantastica di Bologna
che nella cittadina di Ringa aveva creato
una casa di disabili dove loro
si prendevano cura
di questi ragazzi disabili
cercavano di fare
l'abc della riabilitazione.
Almeno avevano un pasto garantito
al giorno
e questa era la casa maledetta
per la gente del posto
infatti non ci andavano i ladri
perché avevano paura
perché lì curavano i disabili e quindi
era un posto maledetto.
Poi col tempo hanno imparato e
visto che tanto maledetto non era
Anzi c'erano due soldini
rispetto alla loro realtà,
però tutto il personale di quella casa lì
era tutto femminile,
non c'era nessun uomo in servizio
anche per la sicurezza.
Incredibile! Tu hai mai avuto
qualche tipo di problema nel tuo percorso
qualche incidente particolare,
qualcuno che ti ha aggredito
o qualcosa di simile?
No assolutamente no.
A parte che eravamo un'equipe.
Io ero diventato un po' l'eroe africano
era tutti i giorni sui loro telegiornale
e sul giornale e quando passavo
mi riconoscevano e mi salutavano
perché il bianco per loro è potere,
rimane il potere
anche se ero una persona potente
con una deambulazione diversa.
Mi hanno sempre steso un tappeto rosso.
L'unico problema è stato
quando abbiamo passato i parchi nazionali
perché lì ci sono gli animali.
Io ho avuto anche la fortuna
di avere a un metro da me un leone
che aveva già mangiato
e non gliene fregava niente di me.
- Direi che è proprio una fortuna!
No, era un maschio.
La femmina è un problema,
ma il maschio che ha mangiato
è il vero re della foresta
non fa niente sta lì sdraiato
non si muove,
anzi in 4 ore si era spostato
di mezzo metro
perché la pianta aveva spostato l'ombra.
- Com'è che questa cosa capita
anche agli umani,
di stare sul divano...
Problemi no di nessun genenere
se non quello di essere disabile
perché ho vissuto l'Africa
da persona normale,
poi da persona disabile
non ci sono i bagni,
non ci sono i servizi,
non c'è l'acqua,
c'è il problema della dissenteria.
E lì come fai?
Vai come gli altri dietro
un cespuglio?
I bagni non ci sono,
non ci sono le strutture.
- Me lo sono chiesto.
Io nel dubbio non mangiamo e non bevevo.
- E sei dimagrito infatti.
Là fortunatamente ero dimagrito
magari ci devo tornare più spesso.
Là ero dimagrito e non bevevo
a meno che non vedevo
le bottiglie confezionate
che aprivo
o non vedevo cucinare la roba cotta
in un certo modo
e mentre gli altri mangiavano
magari nei baretti...
tutti i miei compagni di viaggio
hanno avuto tutti problemi intestinali.
Io ho scampato quel problema
anche perché, cosa fai?
Vai dietro un cespuglio
e poi anche se succede un patatrac
Dove ti pulisci?
Allora nel dubbio ero terrorizzato!
Anche se rimanevo un Masai
non è che ti passa un negozio
di profumeria no?
E' una cosa un po' particolare
però è stata un'esperienza particolare.
Il messaggio è arrivato.
Questo che ti volevo chiedere,
infatti pensi che questa cosa
sia arrivata veramente
nel cuore delle persone?
Sei riuscito a vedere
concretamente qualcosa
Sono usciti dalle loro capanne?
Molto! Sono usciti.
Molte persone ascoltavo quello che dicevo,
mi vedevano
e ho visto molti di loro piangere
perché gli abbiamo toccato dei tasti
che per loro erano inavvicinabili
come per la nostra guida africana.
Poi mi hanno fatto due centri in mio nome.
Un ragazzino di una squadra di sordomuti
in Njombe una volta parlando
con l'interprete LIS,
perché ogni posto
ha un interprete particolare,
questo ragazzo aveva 12 anni,
ha colto il messaggio e ha detto
oggi ho capito che se domani mi impegno
forse ce la potrò fare anch'io.
Non so se conoscete un aforisma
molto particolare che dice:
un ragazzo che va in riva al mare durante
la mareggiata e vede tante stelle marine
che stavano per morire per la mareggiata
e un vecchio gli chiede - Cosa fai?
Butti in acqua una stella marina?
Guarda, ci sono tante stelle marine
non le puoi salvare tutte!
E quel ragazzo gli ha detto:
- no, non le posso salvare tutte
ma a questa le cambio la vita,
e l'ha lanciata in acqua.
E questo è il messaggio che è arrivato
a questo ragazzo.
Se anche il nostro messaggio è
arrivato a una persona che ne viene fuori
è un successo.
Missione compiuta!
Che è esattamente il titolo di questo
tuo intervento.
Perché di fatto tu sei un combattente
ma hai deciso
di portare avanti questa missione.
Quali altre avventure o idee
ti girano per la testa?
Perché tu non sei capace di stare fermo
questo lo abbiamo capito, no?
Adesso è una cosa strana, perché ho fatto
la traversata dell'America
ho fatto questa traversata dell'Africa
sono due cose uniche.
Le persone si aspettano sempre
un qualcosa del dopo.
Cavolo, ho già fatto due cose uniche!
Fatele voi una ogni tanto!
Ho un messaggio,
perché io ho sempre usato lo sport
ho anche giocato a Bolzano tanti anni fa
io ho sempre usato lo sport
come un lavoro,
e uso ora un messaggio di sport
per portare un messaggio di benessere
nel senso "mens sana in corpore sano".
e lo sport non è una medaglia,
lo spot è vivere bene in maniera salutare.
Questa è una cosa meravigliosa,
un messaggio che in pochi
purtroppo si portano appresso.
Tu una volta hai detto
che il cervello si nutre
di quello che riceve
e il cuore di quello che dà.
E' una bella frase però
l'hai fatta quasi diventare un tuo motto
una cosa che senti!
Il cervello certo che si nutre di quello
che riceve!
La gente per acculturarsi deve leggere e
deve nutrire il cervello.
Però a livello emotivo
uno è molto più soddisfatto
se offre un qualcosa a qualcuno,
se gli dai una chance
che non che riceverla
e questo molte volte
le persone preferiscono regalare un dono,
ma non un dono materiale,
ma un dono emotivo più che riceverlo.
Io son così e così sto bene ormai.
- Lo capiamo
E quindi a volte se in certe condiziono
si riesce a dare un messaggio
costruttivo ad altri, ben venga!
Norberto un'ultima battuta.
Tu sei stato nominato
ambasciatore di Parma all'estero
tanti sono i titoli o le referenze
che ti danno.
E' così? Cioè di fatto
mi sembra che ci sia
anche qualcos'altro
che in questi giorni sia accaduto.
Si, mi han fatto ambasciatore
di Parma nel mondo,
l'amministrazione comunale di Parma
e anche il sindaco Pizzarotti
il sindaco abbastanza discusso
quest'anno mi ha dato la benemerenza
della città di Parma come
come persona perché erano società
ero assieme al prosciutto di Parma
io ero un privato per il messaggio
che ho portato in giro
ed è stato un messaggio apolitico
e questa è una cosa che a me piace.
Fantastico!
Oggi si incontra il prosciutto di Parma
con il Teroldego
Abbiamo raccontato una storia
fantastica!
Norberto sei un esempio per tutti!
Davvero un grazie di
cuore a Norberto de Angelis!
Ciao!
(Applausi)